all right guys
bang bang i've got mckenzie here thanks
so much for doing this thanks for having
me
all right let's just jump in why is cnbc
now
putting you on the bitcoin and
cryptocurrency beat like what is going
on in the interest of kind of the media
in terms of what's going on in this
industry
i mean for so long the markets team has
covered bitcoin and so it's been very
focused on price moves
and and what's going on on that side of
it
but i'm joining i joined the tech team
so i cover
business and tech and that's my way into
crypto
and it speaks to the fact that cnbc is
interested not just in the price moves
but we're kind of getting into the weeds
of what's going on and like to the
credit of my editors
they care and they will let me go deep
on things that normally we wouldn't so
what's the difference between the
markets team and the tech team just for
people to understand
yeah so the markets team is very much
focused on like day of price moves why
things are happening
and then with the tech team i you know
friday night i was up until 1am writing
a piece on taproot now usually that
would be a hard
sell uh but i have editors that are very
like plugged into what's going on and
personally i knew it was an important
thing to write about did i think that it
would really hit no but it was the
number one story on cnbc.com this
weekend
really yeah and i think that that speaks
to the fact that like we're
we're finding an audience we didn't even
realize was there
which has been fascinating same thing
this week i was writing about
the mining migration out of china and
where these miners are headed
number one story on cmbc.com and this is
not a credit to me and my
my reporting or writing it's a credit to
the fact that our audience
is really smart and they really care
about things beyond like oh
there was this percentage drop today and
so it feels like uh maybe there's
becoming more sophisticated
like more macro analysis of actual
bitcoin the market the
underlying fundamentals and some of the
players in the market rather than just
price is that kind of a fair way to look
at it yeah yeah
all right why do they pick you like what
is your
uh journey with bitcoin or kind of like
why are you interested in this or why
were they interested in you covering it
yeah so i've
spent five years with cnbc before that i
was with cnn and hong kong and new york
in terms of my journey with crypto it
started when i was in hong kong actually
so it was right around the time
of the mount gox hack and so at dinner
talking to people about what happened
and people didn't really have a lot of
skin in the game
so it wasn't that they felt like such a
huge loss but it just was this
talking point and then a couple years
ago i spoke to a lot of
minors in venezuela who had turned to
you know that practice just because of
everything that was going on with the
national currency and um and so i
started to get into it from that
perspective
and then i mean between 2017 and 2020 it
kind of dropped off our radar a bit and
and then it and then it came back to the
forefront i was reporting a lot on it in
december
and this role opened up with the tech
team and and
and it was kind of is that what was kind
of cool is that the job wasn't like a
crypto reporter
the job was we want a tech reporter and
we want somebody who has a vision for
what this role could be
and i just i think this world is
fascinating and i think there's so much
to unpack and that that's kind of how i
ended up in this chair
so let's walk through your process so um
maybe we'll start with like a taproot
type story right so for those that don't
know
taproot is a software upgrade uh
for bitcoin um it can be quite technical
uh
it can also um have various viewpoints
in terms of like once this
actually is accepted uh what are the
impact going to be the bitcoin what's
the market going to react to it
uh and there's also like a process type
situation where
what is the process from it being more
proposed to actually being
uh accepted and used and so like that's
a lot of complexity what do you do
uh in writing that story to kind of
gather the information so people kind of
understand like the work that goes into
these actual articles
so what i have found is that so many
members of the crypto community of like
the
you know bitcoin believers specifically
have been incredibly helpful
and welcoming and and so my process is i
want to speak to as many people as
possible those who like understand the
mechanics of this those who are trading
it people who are
mining bitcoin people who know it from
all angles because i have so much to
learn and i finally feel like i'm
getting to the place where i know what i
don't know
um so that i at least know the players
and the people that i need to speak to
so it's just like pounding the phones
and like
i that piece that i said that i finished
friday at 1am i was talking to somebody
at midnight who was going through
the final mechanics of it with me i was
having another conversation for another
piece sunday night
and that's that's the big thing just
speaking to the practitioners who
understand it best
and then from there we try to take
things that are very technical because
as you said this upgrade that just
locked is very technical what's
happening and so trying to
turn that into conversational language
that translates to a mainstream audience
is not an easy thing it's the work of a
wizard
no i'd like i still have so i have so
much that i need to do to get better at
it but
that's that's the second stage of the
process just like breaking it down in
in layman's terms and and also making
people care right like so this is not
just something that's
the bitcoin community is interested in
like this is something that it can be
hugely impactful and we can talk about
the reasons why
or not um but but yeah that's that's
what i typically do
and so let's say you go and you talk to
a bunch of market participants and it's
taproot right and you're like hey what
is this why is it important how does it
work what's the process
uh what do you think the potential
impact's going to be all that kind of
stuff you gather all this information
uh i'm assuming you go and you actually
like put together a draft of what you
want to write
and then what's the process from like
your work
through the editing process until it
actually gets published right how much
of that is
reliant on like the work that you've
done versus there's editors or other
folks at cnbc uh that
are into bitcoin or interested in it or
whatever and like what what do they do
with the work before it actually gets
published
yeah so i have an editor who i file my
story to
and he's wonderful like as i was saying
earlier he's the kind of person who
is gonna walk the path with me if i say
that we need to go
and file the story on taproot this
upgrade that not a lot of other people
covered outside the bitcoin world
he hears me um and that's nice because
i've i mean i've worked in newsrooms
around the world and that doesn't always
happen um and then we saw that it worked
there was an audience for it people were
reading it
but the process is i fought like i give
him my story i file my story and and
journalistic
speak and uh that just means send it to
him yeah
just make sure and then he goes through
and he's and
and and he he's skeptical of things in a
good way like of any
he's not skeptical necessarily the
crypto world but of everything that i
write
and so he will kind of go back and forth
with me if there are things that don't
quite resonate or if i don't have enough
you know on both sides of the argument
we get that in there he makes language
edits
and then we publish like it's a pretty
short timeline from from when i
file to when it actually is live on the
site and the
um kind of skeptical nature of it is
more of like editing for
language and concepts and things like
that or it's for like the validity of
what the market persistence
the market participants are saying and
my question really is more around
um i think a lot of folks there's been
this like distrust of the mainstream
media
when they cover this because mainly it's
been uh price coverage
right which is has kind of a specific
slant uh two is it's usually people who
like
maybe they got a sign to do it they're
not really like into it they're not
interested so naturally just the
questions they get asked or the topics
they cover
uh definitely aren't tap root right for
example like it's like the more kind of
surface stuff
uh and then the third thing is um
there's been times where people will
like
do an interview or whatever and then the
thing that gets published is like
completely opposite right and it feels
like right now uh fingers crossed right
like the process that you guys are
implementing at cnbc
is really trying to take like hey here's
what the people on the ground are saying
whether they're right or wrong this is
what they're saying and then like you
said bring it into more conversational
language and i think what's so
fascinating is
it's not being written for the bitcoin
community it's being written for the
everyday investor who read cnbc.com and
there's almost this like melding of
worlds and you and this editor kind of
sitting in the middle trying to like
figure out like how do you do that is
that like a fair way to look at it
yeah and i think i mean you said it
there is this um combative relationship
between mainstream media and between the
crypto community and i hate that
and i want to understand why you know so
many people think that the media in
general
is propagating fud because that's
definitely not my
intention and so everything that i do
every story that i pitch every time i'm
writing something
that i wanna i wanna battle that
stereotype and make sure that like it's
not
it all showing up in and what i write
and what i report not that i need to be
a cheerleader for either side
i just like want to give a very balanced
take on what's going on
and so uh i'm actually trying to think
of your original question i kind of
uh latched on to the mainstream media
side of it it's true though right i mean
in this sense uh i think that um it's a
natural human reaction if you get burnt
once or twice
what do people do they like circle the
wagons right yeah and they literally are
like
we're ready for war and like bitcoiners
are very
uh uh well uh versed
in the meaning and the attacking and
like kind of all this stuff
but all of a sudden uh in some crazy way
like el salvador is a great example
when somebody says hey we see a world
that you guys see we actually
uh have a philosophical alignment or in
your case uh
trying to take an unbiased approach but
saying like i i don't want to be
combative if i actually want to be
i want to understand i want to be able
to kind of share
the views that you guys have uh it
almost it's like bitcoiners get behind
it it becomes a tailwind rather than
like a headwind
yeah i've just been shocked at the
generosity of time and expertise like
people are
tweeting me back like you know at 2am
when i have a story due the next day and
they're weighing in with their thoughts
and
and these are people who have sometimes
i've never met before other people have
been on the phone with i
some who i've met at the bitcoin
conference and that's i mean
to have been able to source up this
quickly uh and to have people
really be so welcoming and encouraging
of of
yeah and it's it's not to like it's not
to you know push their side of the
argument necessarily it's really just
helped me get into the side
inside the mechanics of how these things
work so i've appreciated that
and going back to something else you
said i was looking at this report and it
was
out the research group i think is called
clover
and they were looking at uh mainstream
media coverage of the crypto world from
2013 to 2018.
and there are some like i i understand
why as you said like some from the
crypto community feel burned like one of
the
you know report uh one of the things i
did in the report is the fact that
you saw this uptick in coverage always
when there was a big sell-off and so
you know that naturally kind of skews to
negative coverage i will say cnbc like
our ranking was
was balanced on the positive and
negative coverage which is great and
it's also a big part of why i'm there
and
and doing this job with cnbc uh but i
get it i i get why
there are hurt not i don't not hurt
feelings but why there's skepticism of
of
of certain media outlets what's the
process for getting the other
side so like as much as uh people want
to say
um bitcoin is amazing it's inevitable
it's whatever right and
i'm more bullish than most yeah uh you
gotta
in your role talk to the people who
completely disagree
yeah and so what's the process in terms
of getting like the bearish argument or
the counterpoint to what uh kind of
comes out of the bitcoin community is it
the same thing just with different types
of people
exactly like i'm talking to a lot of
people on wall street and
and and well the mindset there is
shifting
with a lot you know with several people
it isn't shifting and so i just i i want
to hear it from both sides i want the
best storytellers and argument makers to
kind of debate it
and i and i go back and forth like so
when i'm doing interviews i don't do all
from one side and then the other it's
like i'm constantly
ping-ponging between the two so that i
can put the best arguments from one side
to the other side and vice versa just so
that i can fully get in it and and like
i said
i have so much to learn still uh i'm
nowhere
near where i need to be um that's what
you'll learn in bitcoin nobody knows
nobody's done learning like that's part
of the beauty of it is the
multi-disciplinary like intersection
right so just nobody's done learning
which is
uh exciting but also like can feel
overwhelming at times of like oh my god
i slept so much longer and like every
spare second like i because i like to go
i do distance running and i like i
listen to podcasts like obviously i
listen to you
bitcoin audible like guy swann has
taught me a bunch too but like
i'm just in every spare minute that i
have i'm trying to
take it in by osmosis i'm laughing
because you didn't mention the third
best podcast in all of bitcoin which is
uh peter mccormick's what bitcoin did
you just didn't mention it he must not
be very good i mean peter's a great guy
i like i like peter a lot but yeah you
listen if you don't have a good podcast
on a good podcast
catch up here a little bit uh all right
let's talk about bitcoin mining love you
peter
in terms of uh the mining story that you
did you really were focused on kind of
china
and the hash rate shifting out of china
so you walk through like kind of what
were some of the takeaways for you in
that topic
so i was kind of informally talking to a
lot of people when i was in miami the
first time around and every single
person kept bringing up this like
drain of 50 to 60 percent of the hash
rate out of china
and how people weren't talking enough
about it
and so then i just started to get in the
weeds of it uh and and having lived in i
lived in hong kong for three years with
cnn
uh spent you know a lot of time going
back and forth between uh beijing and
and hong kong and so is personally
interested uh
for for different reasons and there i
mean there are so many angles here like
yes the destination side of it like
where are they going to go
um and and that's important to me not
just from
the standpoint of what does this mean
for the us and
our mining infrastructure will become
more progressive in those policies will
we move faster
to build um you know the systems
necessary to host those miners
but it's also very interesting to me in
terms of like the climate debate around
bitcoin
and it's something where i've been i've
been wanting to do a piece for a while
on this and i think the new cambridge
data comes out next month and so i
cannot wait to sink my teeth into that
but where they go will really decide
the direction this argument takes you
know um and and it's a toss-up right
because like
miners leaving china is not a great
thing necessarily like there's tons of
hydropower in addition to tons of like
coal mines right and so i mean i don't
know if it's a full net net
but like a full wash when you have them
all exit but
where they go will decide what people
say about bitcoin's carbon footprint for
the next decade
i think yeah and i think part of what's
so fascinating about china is so there's
certain
uh chinese provinces where it's almost
100 hydro right and it's like
actually that should be the lighthouse
on the
uh kind of uh hill if you will in terms
of what we want people to do to be 100
renewable
um at the same time there's a lot of
examples where that's not what we want
people to do and it's the coal
but the u.s i think on a net basis
you know kind of side by side of china
is a more green grid but to your point
you could just go do a coal mine in the
united states and that's not much better
right and it's actually a negative if
you went from renewable in china and to
uh
non-renewable in the united states so
there's nuance here not just
oh switched countries and it solves all
the problems yeah and then kazakhstan
like it's a next-door neighbor to china
that ate a cool climate uh
they're very lacks on their building
policies and it's coal powered
so i mean i'm i mean i'm fascinated to
see where they go i think for the time
being i was talking to nick carter about
this too that
the the hash rate would probably go
offline there right and so the miners
who are still mining are going to be a
little bit richer
um and we might see special like
zones set up to absorb these miners but
yeah one i think also in the united
states what's really fascinating
is uh you're getting some migration just
in general
uh but it seems like the us is much more
innovative in finding uh various energy
sources so yeah
you know oil and gas and kind of flare
gas capture
yeah there's great american mining a
couple other companies that are doing it
they seemed to be really a us-based
strategy
uh before it went anywhere else but you
could see very quickly like hey where
else do they have oil
like well this could be it you know done
in many many different uh
regions very quickly and so in some way
it feels like china
served as um kind of a breeding gown
and was a very big part of the mining
hash rate for a while
that's now shifted and is changing
rapidly but also the
types of energy is we're getting more
right flare gas capture wasn't the thing
five years ago i'm writing a story on
that as well okay i'm trying to try to
get there
talk talk about this well i so do you
know steve barber
i do yeah so basically uh i've been
he's been teaching me about this world
obviously runs a company that sets up
these different oil fields with the you
know the mobile mining setups
and i think it's fascinating and and uh
i just kind of want to break out that
process of of what this means in terms
of like the logistics of it but also
what does it mean in terms of
you know capturing that otherwise
stranded uh natural gas is better than
flaring it so what are the
like the environmental impacts like what
are the net positives with this
so that's something i'm interested in
and then also nuclear power right like i
was talking to the mayor of miami
yesterday and he is
very keen to absorb some of these uh
migrant miners who need a home
uh and and he wants to channel that
nuclear power so i've got that story
coming out now or it might be live right
now like my boss was looking at
so he um there's two things there so on
the flare gas
yeah what's fascinating to me about that
argument is it's not just
oh we're gonna get the flare gas and
we're using the mine
we're actually reversing or preventing
yeah environmental damage right right so
instead of this being flared it's being
diverted
and so you get advantage for bitcoin but
you also get protection of the
environment
which is like you know that's galaxy
brain stuff for the critics because they
don't want to talk about the fact that
you actually could be improving the
situation let alone
uh not making it worse but then when you
start talking to like the mayor
you get this weird world of like it's
kind of capitalism and private markets
but it's also kind of
state-sponsored uh support and
what i don't think people quite have
understood yet is
the states are probably going to become
massive proponents of this stuff
oh right i mean texas is very crypto
friendly and specifically trying to
build up its mining infrastructure
wyoming uh another destination georgia
kentucky have you seen what they did in
kentucky uh they uh
they put the coal mines right they
dropped taxes
for minors and basically are trying to
use taxes as an incentive for people to
come there and mine
and what does it do it not only brings
economic development
uh in terms of like the the money that
is mined and all that
brings jobs right it brings all sorts of
educated people like
there's a uh industry associated with
this it's not just
hey we came we showed up you know we put
some computers in the wall and like we
laughed
and so it just feels like um it's easy
to point fingers and yell about the
environmental impact it's easy to yell
about like the
country uh distribution but when you
actually unpack it like
mining actually may be pretty good like
there's a strong argument that bitcoin
mining is the
greatest incentive a renewable power uh
kind of r d right now yeah
people don't like that but i think
that's true no and i've talked to a lot
of people about that and it and
the the the kid like the casting shade
on that is always like the issue of
like intermittent energy use and so you
ultimately it is more profitable to be
mining 24 7
than it is just during daylight hours or
you know so the
the issue of like storing it um if they
could figure that out
well longer story for sure but uh the
idea of bitcoin being a battery
right becomes like this whole thing
where a bunch of people
um you know and myself included who are
like look you're essentially storing
energy in bitcoin if you have 24 7
persistent demand for that energy
um and so i guess that then brings up
tesla like what are your thoughts there
and
or uh tesla and elon in general uh a
bunch of tweets and stuff
have you done any work there or kind of
formulating any thoughts around are they
gonna eventually get into mining
is the concern legitimate is he just
having fun on the internet like
what are kind of your thoughts yeah so i
mean i've had a couple different
conversations with people about this and
so like one argument
is that uh he he really understands this
world he understands the nuances of
mining
so the reason that he would say
something that is a very like narrow
view of this
argument is because he's laying the
groundwork for something that he's going
to release like whether that's a new
battery or i don't i don't know what
he's going to do but like maybe it's
like
you know booming the runways for
something that's coming down the pike
or maybe shareholders were just like you
need to
button it up and and uh walk it back a
bit and and of course like since then
he's kind of reverse course he said if
mining becomes what 50
more whatever the language was around
that 50 renewable
and it could be proven that he would
basically start accepting bitcoin again
yeah
to buy at least one model of uh tesla's
vehicles
so i don't know exactly where i fall on
this uh on this
he didn't he didn't sell any bitcoin so
right how big of a concern is it really
right that's kind of the view
i actually think that net net he's going
to end up being a
um a positive impact on the industry
it's just you know a little chaos along
the way
a lot of chaos along the way what's up
guys bang bang i hope you're enjoying
this conversation but before we go any
further i want to quickly tell you about
today's sponsor
blockfi blockfish got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan
against your crypto collateral you can
use their cryptocurrency exchange and
have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com go check it out
and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it uh what
other ideas are you interested in for
stories right so people who are
listening a bunch of bitcoiners like
what are some of the things that uh that
you find fascinating or want to learn
more about
uh a couple different things so one is
how real is it that countries could
nationalize mining pools
oh interesting so not just mining but
natural mining pools themselves
yeah and and does that i mean what
complications does it introduce does
that introduce
introduce another layer of taxation we'd
have to deal with that's like
one thing i'm kind of into uh
policymakers to like are they scared of
stable coins like what what is that
dynamic there
i defend what policy makers that's true
so some of them love the idea and then i
my editor has wanted me to do a piece on
just what is d5 for so long and then
once i get past like the what is defy
like you know conversations it you know
just listen to one of your podcasts
about this but kind of the
the the bitcoin ecosystem for define how
that's changing and how tap root might
be
um you know changing uh well obviously
it's making changes to the smart
contract and what does that mean for
for uh the world of d5
my list goes on all right what else
let's go what other ideas do you have
um i want to get into ethereum and the
question of centralization
did you did you pause before you start
talking about ethereum yeah
all right ethereum and and what do you
say in the question of the question of
centralization
um basically is ethereum decentralized
or centralized yeah
oh you should definitely write about
that okay that i think that there will
be
plenty of people who listen to this who
will have ideas on both sides like
it i don't think i've read yet
uh maybe i'm wrong on this and some
people will correct me for sure if i'm
wrong
i don't think yet i've read a piece that
really gets at the heart of
how do you measure it and then where are
we
today where were we and where are we
going right because
there's some element of like none of
these systems are uh static
and so like bitcoin today is more
decentralized than it used to be
it's definitely more decentralized than
it was in 20 uh 2009
right and so like it's getting more and
more decentralized so it's not only like
where are we but i also think like the
arc of progress or
or the uh the direction of travel is
important as well
i'll leave it for other people to
comment as to what they think
and then i i mean there's so much more
to do on mining in general
uh so mining is like a big focus of
yours it seems like as of late it is
just because
of what's happening right now and just
the
the places that are trying to roll out
the red carpet what does this mean for
like reshaping the energy grid in texas
which right now is
extremely problematic right i mean with
all the storms that happened earlier
this year and and there's
it's been in the headlines again
recently and the last thing i have on my
list i mean there are more things that i
wanted to cover but the idea of green
coins
um green coin like esg bitcoin yeah yeah
okay a lot of people are not i think
they just think it doesn't make sense um
and then there are like coins that have
just been created with with that in mind
so chia is on my
is on my radar okay
what oh what does that look like esg
bitcoin let's talk about it for a second
okay
what are the arguments that you've heard
and then i'll give you my
my perspective okay so i was talking to
and i'm gonna i'm gonna butcher the
argument the wonderful argument that
fred teal laid out but uh he was getting
into the fact that kind of
um differentiating origin between those
that have been
you know ethically mined from those that
aren't is going to
be probably participants of the market
may say that they want it to be green
but do they want to pay more for it no
and so that will ultimately end up being
problematic uneconomical and then it
won't
it won't maintain basically he's arguing
that esg bitcoin won't actually be a
thing
even though people are saying that they
want it to be a thing because they're
not willing to actually pay an economic
premium for it and if you won't pay more
for it then
it all falls apart it's just virtually
signaling that is my understanding of it
i don't want to misquote anybody
i interviewed him he said right in that
seat i'm positive at least
that's that's the argument he told me
yeah maybe he's changed his mind i don't
think so but that was the argument he
told me yeah which was different than
the argument that
marathon the the company he now runs uh
had taken
60 days before so it was interesting
that they had changed their mind on this
and a lot of it had to do with the fact
that people were not willing to pay more
they at one point thought people would
be willing to pay more so they kind of
the curtain got revealed and they're
like wait a minute this is just virtue
signaling we're not going to do it
what is the argument for it that you've
heard i i mean it just kind of goes back
to
the the question of the ethical side of
mining and whether
it's environmental footprint wanting to
just counter that even if it has
even if it does if it comes at a premium
uh
i i i don't i mean like let's i haven't
fully reported this out do i have the
nuance side of the counter argument not
as much
yeah all right the stat that i heard
recently
uh i did not go verify the stat but uh
i'm going to take this person at the
at uh at their word i saw them tweet it
bitcoin's energy consumption is less
than two percent
of just the energy consumption needed to
propagate the
us military industrial complex
which is the security system for the u.s
dollar compared to the security of the
bitcoin network
and so like that's like an interesting
framework doesn't have to be the only
framework but like
okay that's a data point when you then
start to look at how much of that is
green
zero right i don't know the real numbers
but like not a high percentage right
uh i i don't know if you've ever seen
like they'll they'll say uh uh look at
the green
uh energy consumption of the us dollar
and they'll show like the battleships
and like the
the uh fighter jets um but i do think
that there's this argument of like
it makes sense for people to in an
elementary analysis say oh
it should be clean it should be
renewable it should be whatever
but i think that bitcoin has this way of
exposing these topics and really
separating them from a uh what should
happen from like a social
uh standpoint what's politically correct
from a pure economic
and i think that the beauty of bitcoin
is that it's an economic
incentive machine and forget what the
social consensus is people are going to
do with the cheapest thing
in terms of production of bitcoin
because that's how they make the most
money
and it's economically advantageous to go
get renewable energy yeah
because it's way more profitable for you
it is i mean just look at the numbers of
like the average cost of renewables
versus
it's not even close so like market
forces are going to force everyone to
become renewable
yeah regardless of any regulation
policies like any of this other stuff by
the way same thing with cars
like it's gonna happen why because
people are gonna want the electric
vehicles
but what you start to understand is like
the people who are calling for esg
bitcoin aren't the ones who are actually
doing anything like they're not building
the mining facilities they're not doing
any of the actual
work they're just the ones who are kind
of nitpicking and saying oh
i don't want this because it's not esg
compliant or i have a mandate
from somewhere else to invest capital
based on that
but i always try to separate out like
but just economic
machine is going to force everyone to
become renewable and so like this is a
mute point to begin with
but also by the way you're not willing
to pay more so is it really more
valuable to have esg bitcoin versus not
which i think is fred teal's whole
argument of just
the economic incentive kind of exposes
who's real and who's not mm-hmm fair
yeah fair
all right what other stories anything
else i feel like there are so many
things i know i'm asking
what's the craziest thing that you've
thought about writing about
like when it comes to bitcoin crypto etc
the thing that you're like
yeah i don't know if i could like
actually learn about it or if people
would talk to me about it or whatever
well this is i mean and it kind of goes
to
a podcast that you already put out there
but i really think
my taproot article on saturday initially
had like ethereum in the headline and
and kind of talking about that dynamic
of um you know with bitcoin adding more
functionality to its smart contracts
what does that mean in terms of the d5
space like does bitcoin become more of a
player over ethereum even though
ethereum has long kind of dominated the
world of d5 and people want to build
dapps on top of that infrastructure and
so
i don't understand everything well
enough to oh i mean i want to learn more
but i am
afraid to touch that argument myself you
should do it
only because uh if you
fear going and talking about a topic
that's probably where you're gonna learn
the most
and what i think if i was in your seat
right you do whatever you want
go talk to a bunch of the folks in what
is now called d5 which is always
interesting because bitcoin is the
largest d5 product but that's a whole
other thing
um and then go see where they're
building some of them or
many of them are building on ethereum
right there's certain functionality that
it provides throughput fees whatever
that makes that attractive
now there's other smart contract
platforms that people are starting to
build on
go talk to them and then talk to the
bitcoin d5 or layer two
you know bitcoin folks and my guess is
that uh
and this is controversial they actually
all agree on more than you would expect
but the key pieces of difference make
the picture
very very clear so it's like you know i
don't know 70 percent of things they all
agree on which is like i always joke i'm
like do we all want something that's a
decentralized financial system
like every single one of those groups
you're like yeah we want that
okay so where's the disagreement how do
we get there where is it built
and then all the nuances you know
they're like okay well we need like
cheap fees and
high throughput okay we all agree on
that like okay
where does that get built not agreement
why and then the fundamental differences
are like really exposed and
what i think is so fascinating is it's
also what's the
timeline that people actually want this
to be available yeah
so if you have a 10-year time horizon
versus 100 versus one
well there's different technical things
that end up getting built based on if it
needs to be ready in one year to
swallow the legacy financial system
versus 100 years
and i think that we always uh the
elementary analysis is just like
static view of the world but it's more
the directional progress
more so than with the static vehicle
right mm-hmm in terms of coverage what
do you think we're missing
and and when i say man you'll put me on
the spot all right
no but i want to magic started laughing
he's like damn she got him
but i want to get better and i also want
to like repair this
like we were talking about i think
there's three things yeah okay ready
you're ready
there's a certain portion of the market
that uh gets covered
not because of merit but because of
uh the speculative hype and bubble
i'm torn on how a cnbc or somebody like
that
uh thinks about it because part of it is
it will be consumed by some portion of
the population as having merit because
cnbc talks about it
at the same time what they're really
covering if you look at like the
dogecoin
uh stuff they're not so much talking
about the asset what they're doing is
they're talking about the actions of the
investors around the asset yeah so
they're reporting on like look at this
thing that is new and and different and
whatever
but then the consumption is like oh
douchecoin is just an equivalent to
bitcoin like okay that's probably not
what you want people to take away from
the story
right so like i think there's that
element of it which just like uh i'm
glad
i'm i'm actually uh very glad that i'm
not in the sea that has to make those
calls because i think that's a very
complex issue there might not even be a
right answer
um but that clearing that up would be
like a huge
boost because then it just says like oh
okay checks off the box of like
they understand where value is accruing
and like and like merit versus
things that uh are reporting on like the
actions of
the community right so separating that i
think important
second thing is uh there's lots and lots
of
coverage of the price of the tokens
there's actually a lack of coverage on
the companies that are building in this
space
so crypto is weird because everyone
always thinks about the
tokens the coins there's a daily price
and the volatility all this stuff
many of the companies are actually more
important than
the individual tokens and things like
that and so
it almost seems like the boring part of
the industry but i think that like those
businesses end up empowering so much of
this um
and so like how you do it which ones all
that's up for debate but like the equity
side i think is really important
and then the third thing is like you're
already doing this
uh but if we had this conversation six
months ago cmc and nobody else was doing
it
bitcoin is gonna end up being one of the
if not the most valuable asset
in the world it is global in nature
nobody in el salvador cares
about ninety-five percent of the news in
the united states
a lot of people in el salvador care
about bitcoin
that's el salvador great go country by
country around the world
bitcoin is probably one of the
most common shared topics across the
world
because it defies generations it defies
um cultures it defies language like
it's just this global asset and so
i'm shocked that platforms just like
we're going to go
all in and we're going to cover this in
great depth like the taproot article i
think was when i was like oh wait a
second this is different like
that would not have happened six months
ago 12 months ago
and so i think that like you're already
seeing it like it's the number one
article like go do more of that
right and by the way like it doesn't
have to be a positive article like it
could be
hey bitcoiners have gone crazy and like
they're doing something that's like
stupid here's the argument that's why
it's stupid
okay sure but it's just a topic that is
going to continue to be the number one
topic on
these websites because it's pulling from
uh
such a global basis and i think that's
the part that people like haven't
figured out yet
i don't know that's just mine very
helpful and that's the thing like i
really i
so many of these ideas come from like
informal conversations that i'm having
where i'm reporting out one story and
then i realize that's the wrong story to
be writing like there's something else
that's happening that really
just needs some error that needs to be
put in print and and i mean in terms of
like my next steps like as i build out
this be like i just want to be speaking
to as many people as possible
all right so that was my last question
before the rapid fires how do
bitcoiners people in the crypto
community folks who are
who are uh critics as well yeah how do
they help you
like what's the best way for them to
help you get better at doing this
dm me on twitter okay kenzie sagalos
i really welcome uh conversations advice
like anything
dms are open just have them dm you and
dm with
whatever their like perspective is on
various
topics yeah stories that should be like
told that aren't being told if they just
want to like send me their number and we
can have a phone call like i'm
i'm very open okay that's a very
dangerous thing to say
in this world because people are gonna
send you memes they're gonna send you
their phone number
and they're going to send you all kinds
of stuff is that a mistake no
it's fine we'll see what happens yeah
not my fault if
you get weird things uh-huh please
people don't be weird
um all right so just dmu story ideas but
also things that they see you tweeting
about or whatever if they have
perspectives on it they can just dm you
you read them all
yeah they're all good okay uh three
questions before we
wrap up every journalist has a great
answer to this what's the most important
book you've ever read
uh god that is such a hard question
i know i mean i i feel like i should be
giving a non-fiction book but i always
think of the sun also rises in this one
line where it's just like you
you can't get away from yourself by
going elsewhere essentially
um and it's just like it rings true i
think that people try to find themselves
outside of
um the the seat that they're in and
wherever you go
there you are and so i think that being
really honest with yourself about what
you're doing your priorities and how you
approach life is
is pretty key what what is the name of
the book the sun also rises the sun also
rises ernest hemingway
ah yeah i uh journalist who also wrote
novels
yeah yeah or ernest hemingway uh i
always
uh when i hear ernest hemingway i always
think of which
i don't know why i do this hunter s
thompson
two different people but like for some
reason i don't know if it's like they're
always seen in black and white photos or
what but like
i always think of those two together uh
second question is sleep schedule
so our friends over at sleep have
thermoregulated bed turn it hot turn it
cold i sleep on an ice cold
sleep like eight or nine hours now game
like
literally the number one thing that i
tell people you should go do
is get this damn bed so that you can
sleep cold and you get deeper
uh or you get more deep sleep so you
still sleep the same let's say eight
hours
uh rather than maybe four hours of deep
sleep you might get five or five and a
half
and by extending the deep sleep you
actually feel more rested so their whole
goal is eventually instead of eight
hours you might be able to sleep six but
if it's all deep sleep then
you saved time and got the same rest
what's your sleep schedule
but being totally frank i'm not probably
sleeping as much as i should right now
okay
um but like five to six hours
five to six oh that's bad all right what
time do you go to sleep
i i eat berries between like 12 and one
and then i'll get up between like five
and six
listen i'm telling you
i used to literally i said to somebody
recently on the podcast uh
when i first met my wife she said to me
like
hey you don't really sleep that much
like what's up with that and i literally
remember i said wolves don't sleep and
she's like what and i was like i don't
know where that came from but like
like that was my mentality was just like
yeah i'll sleep when i'm dead
then i started to sleep and i was like
oh like you don't even understand the
value of sleep until you start yeah and
i sound
ridiculous no you don't sound ridiculous
and i think part of the problem so
my beat uh at cnbc it's it's crypto but
it's also
cyber security and so and i i'm within
my first few months on the new job so
like sourcing up and closing that
knowledge gap
got it okay yeah after the first couple
of weeks then sleep
uh third question is aliens are you
believer or non-believer
yeah i mean why because it seems
outrageous that we would be the only
life form in the universe
just cuz so big i mean yeah but i mean
we're just i feel like this is not gonna
be an eloquent answer but we're like
one small planet in this very like sure
big space like i just don't understand
how it's possible that there wouldn't be
some other life form
i haven't said this in a while so it
might be a surprise to some people when
i was in high school
uh there's nine planets at one point i
think when i was in college
pluto it wasn't a planet then became a
planet again or so there's some
controversy around pluto
only nine though there's now like a
thousand planets
and i don't know where the rest came
from but there's a lot of work that's
been done in space over the last like 20
years
and so uh if there's a thousand planets
and then there are more stars in the sky
than grains of sand on earth
there's got to be something out there
okay so you also are a believer
oh hardcore okay yeah but uh i don't
believe we'll be able to
contact them during my lifetime because
they're too far away
so like they're out there somewhere nice
to meet you whatever
hundreds of years from now but not
probably not while we're alive we'll see
what one question you have for me to
finish up
what is the best piece that you've read
in the last week
or month oh and last week or month
those aren't nearly as like that
question is not nearly as good yeah
i can't say the best piece of media that
i've consumed in the last week it will
definitely get me uh
in trouble um i don't care if it's not
cnbc
no no no no no no not in trouble with me
no
yeah i can't say that one um i would say
that i'll give you two
people that i read pretty regularly that
i think are very interesting
uh and i'll caveat it with um they're
both independent thinkers
they write things in a very
um kind of uh
piercing way so they get right at the
truth of what they're saying
but they say it in a very entertaining
and engaging way which
turns some people off but uh matt taibi
and
uh mike salana both they take things
that happen in the world
let's say for example uh mike might
write about
cancel culture and he'll literally nail
the topic like he'll be like look
there's people who
were powerless before now they feel like
they have power they go after people
they weaponize things
or whatever and he'll like nail it and
then some people read and be like oh my
god this guy like
he wrote 12 pages about like castle
culture and like they freak out
but i like reading the people who write
from an independent thinking standpoint
because what they
end up doing is they end up stretching
like the intellectual muscle so like if
you just read
name your publication you just get that
you're within some lane because that's
what they're allowed to write that's
what their
editors want them to write right that's
what uh their audience wants whatever so
you're
within that the more that you start to
get outside of that
you're literally just like stretching
the intellectual muscle and sometimes
like you know you might stretch it too
far by the way
that was a little weird like you know
let me come back within the the the
you know within the boundaries of like
of my thought process
but like i just think more people could
do better from doing that and so it's
less of like one piece it's just like
those two people in particular just off
top of my head
uh glenn greenwald's been doing a
fantastic job of just calling out
nonsense
um and then uh let me think of who else
i would say those three have done a
really good job and then there's a um
a woman i'm gonna forget her name uh
planet's gonna kill me
she used to be the writer of all the
profiles at
gq and so she did the rock like a bunch
of people
uh she's fantastic anytime she writes
anything i like
almost stop everything and read it uh
because it's just like um
learning from people and like their
stories and all that uh and she has like
a really elegant
eloquent way of doing it and uh there's
a story that she
appreciates the same woman she wrote
chris hemsworth
was he captain america i don't know
one of those guys there's brothers right
calling my brother's like ah they're all
like pumps or whatever
uh and she like went out
drinking with him and then like
slept at his house and then wrote an
article
and there's this whole thing and you
read it and you're like
that might be one of the best articles
i've read in a while it's like paulina
loves it as well
and it's just uh the way that she writes
is like very unique
and it like really gets at hey this is
who this person is so i don't know
thank you for the recommendations i'm
definitely going to check them well it
would help if i remembered her name
i feel like i have enough to google that
and find her instagram yeah yeah yeah
gq uh pro that's your big that's the
profiles
um all right where can we send people uh
twitter
to find you yeah twitter um and then if
you want to read my stuff
i've got a bio page on cnbc all right so
just go cnbc.com search your name and
then it comes up
or i guess google um and then anyone
this is me this is not her saying this
anyone who has ideas of stories for
please go dmr be nice um but also
i think that uh just introducing them
right because it might even be a story
you're working on now
but in the future uh if you're looking
to talk to somebody who does abc
whatever they should
if they if you know who they are you can
reach out to them yeah exactly awesome
all right thank you so much for doing
this thanks for having me
this is an intimidating chair to be
sitting in it's a five dollar home depot
in which many important people have
sat across from you so anyways thanks